well I think and I think the biggest the
deepest impact is really in economic
ideas and there's just a lot that the
kind of old confidence in the idea that
the state could you know that by taking
the state had the ability to take
positive action in order to to change
economic relationships and create a more
equal fair just economy I think that the
contemporary i'm a proud party you know
even under obama is not committed to
that in the same way and I think one
place we really see this actually is
with regard to labor unions and the you
know really complete lack of commitment
of the Obama administration to passing
labor law reform you know I think we see
it all over though I mean I think you
can see it in the health care debate and
the way in which what's actually being
talked about now is is substantially
watered down and is quite far from a you
know anything like a single-payer
program which might actually which many
experts think we would have the you know
greatest chance of actually delivering
on the goal of truly universal health
care but it's not on the table it's just
nowhere in the discussion not know where
but it's not it's definitely not in the
in its not bus being talked about in
Congress so so I think that kind of
thing you know there's there's a way in
which the the center of political
opinion has has really shifted
is Obama post-partisan president well no
i don't i don't think that it it is i
think the whole concept of post-partisan
is is problematic and that it's you know
the way that things really change is
through people being willing to take
positions and fight for them and I think
the idea you can avoid the fight or
transcendent in politics is just not
right and Obama adds a community
organizer I should have known better you
know I think in the nineteen thirty-six
election we have FDR speaking Madison
Square Garden saying if the forces of
organized business our against united
against him and he welcomes their hatred
that's not a post-partisan position but
that is the kind of position that you
need to i think really make things
change and i think with obama it's
interesting I he could he tries you know
to you back away from conflict but the
it's impossible to actually avoid it I
mean it you know we did the ways in
which he's been attacked for the reforms
that he's tried to put through
especially in health care you can see
this dynamic where he's putting
something for that seems quite moderate
really but it doesn't matter how
moderate it is it still gets attacked
and so that's why i think it's it's it's
I don't think he is a post person
president but I also think it wasn't
really the right thing to try for